[Music]
Americans we love ice cream each person
eats about 24 quarts of it per year and
that's for one big reason it tastes
amazing but someone had to teach Ben and
Jerry's how to do it turns out that guy
he works at Penn State
this is dr. Bob
Robert hold on okay this is dr. Bob
Roberts
he teaches ice cream courses at Penn
State I do I have two courses ice cream
short course and ice cream 101 side note
these are the type of books ice cream
professors read ok back to the story
part of the reason that ice cream is so
good in the US is that we've been
teaching ice cream for 125 years and Bob
he's been teaching at Penn State for 25
of those and he's had some pretty famous
students companies like Unilever nestle
Breyers Ben and Jerry's you name the
company they've sent people that's
because the Penn State Creamery is on
the forefront of ice cream technology
ice cream is a formulated food there is
no naturally occurring ice cream you
have to put the ingredients together and
process it to make ice cream Bob in his
department they spend their time
figuring out how to make ice cream even
better when we look at studying ice
cream we study ice cream from cow to the
cone so we look at what happens on the
farm what happens with the milk wait
there's a farm we have a herd of about
250 or so milking Holsteins and yes they
are on campus so yeah he knows ice cream
but he says that he's not an ice cream
purist I'm not sure what an ice cream
purist is but I wouldn't eat frozen
yogurt if I had the opportunity to ice
cream yeah well that does make sense
considering he is the authority on ice
cream Bob what's your favorite flavor
mmm don't see the leche
yeah cakes cookies and brownies no we're
not going to show you how to make them
because they can be made with ease
thanks to Betty Crocker who was born in
1921 in Minnesota well kind of in 1921
the Washburn Crosby company now known as
General Mills ran a contest for people
to complete the puzzle for the most
coveted prize a pin cushion yes one of
your very own surprisingly a lot of
people wrote in to claim their prize but
with a little PS they wanted baking
advice so the customer service
department began to reply and to make
their tips seem more genuine they sign
their letters Betty Crocker Betty
because it was a cheery all-around
American sounding name and Crocker after
a board member not being a real person
didn't stop Betty Crocker from having a
very successful radio show the Betty
Crocker cooking school of the air with a
different accent in every state but the
lies don't stop there let's talk about
that added ingredient the egg you don't
need to add a fresh egg to powdered cake
mix but science says it makes us feel
like we aren't cheating and were better
providers so thanks Betty Crocker for
making us all feel like we know how to
bake
[Music]
popcorn movies a match made in theatre
heaven but there was a time when this
was banned
[Music]
popcorn has been around for over 8000
years but when it hit American streets
in the mid-1800s it took off it was
cheap and could be mass-produced on the
go not to mention it smelled amazing
it was the go-to snack at circuses
sporting events and fairs in fact the
only place you wouldn't find popcorn was
at the movies you see going to the
movies used to be a major event the only
people that went were fancy rich folks
because he had to be educated enough to
read fancy like there was even a
coat-check but there was definitely no
concession stand there was however
popcorn street vendors who set up shop
outside theaters they made a killing
selling to waiting theater goers theater
goers that started smuggling their pop
treats inside not cool early movie
theaters kindly asked patrons check
their popcorn before entering then in
1927 films started adding sound meaning
everyone went to the movies the Great
Depression followed making movies a
cheap escape huge crowds plus crunch
muffled sound equaled another revenue
opportunity for theater owners by 1945
over half the popcorn consumed in
America was being eaten at the movies a
marriage that has continued ever since
[Music]
[Music]
cotton candy
who knew sugar and air could taste so
sweet
well a guy named James Marcin an amateur
inventor whose occupation and taste buds
didn't exactly aligned he was a dentist
and during his lifetime James even
became the president of the Tennessee
Dental Association don't forget to floss
but he was also a confectionery
enthusiast with a passion for culinary
advancement he paired with John C Walton
an old friend and fellow confectioner
together the two designed incur patented
what they called the electronic candy
machine the device rapidly spun and
melted sugar through small holes until
it was fluffy at nearly 70% air they
called the Nutri fairy floss they
introduced their product at the 1904
World's Fair selling it in small wooden
boxes for 25 cents each that's about six
dollars today fairy floss was a huge
success in six months they sold over
68,000 boxes crusing in today's money
around four hundred and forty thousand
dollars but despite the success of the
sugar spun business Mars and return
teased a job as a dentist so next time
the dentist tells you you're eating too
many sugary treats well blame him
you
you
[Music]
everybody loves ice cream
even those who say they don't like ice
cream still no why should we use ice
cream as a way to support our community
[Music]
my name is Michael Mikey Cole and I own
Mike he likes an ice cream I did not
always sell ice cream I was born in the
Lower East Side of New York City's
Village two blocks from the shop
bustling drugs at one point I ended up
getting caught and I'm going to jail for
six months a few years ago my mother got
sick I promise to her that I wouldn't be
locked up anymore I'd do the wrong
things ice cream was something that just
came into my life at a time when I
didn't really know what I was kind of
doing this is pop culture inspired ice
cream we object and chill couple shuffle
Ice Ice Baby employ mint condition
southern hospitality and we have smooth
operator
a bunch of famous people have come by
here futures our fan walking know as a
fan Hillary Clinton's a fan we have a
lot of other fans out
I still live two blocks from the store
part of our job is to still be heavily
in the community and so kids come in
here with a a on a report card to give
them a free scoop of ice cream it's to
show them that we are the same as done
so I'm just a little older but I'm still
the same child at heart
and if you can find something that you
like and you're passionate about
go for it to just go for it you know
don't don't not go for your games go for
every last on the slab
[Music]
[Music]
you probably recognize these ice-cream
pellets as the ice cream of the future
they're dippin dots a summertime steep
but this confectionery treat didn't
start as well ice cream
it started as cow feed dippin dots were
invented in the 80s not by an ice cream
brand but by a microbiologist Curtis
jones specialized in cryogenics in 1987
he was working for a biotech company in
Kentucky trying to figure out how to
make food for farm animals more
efficient his big breakthrough came when
he flash froze cattle feed 350 degrees
below zero which produces small pellets
serendipitously Curtis loved making ice
cream next thing he knew he was using
liquid nitrogen to freeze ice cream at
extremely low temperatures and ended up
with small beads of it when eaten the
natural heat of the mouth melted the
beads and thus dippin dots was born a
year later he formed the company out of
his parents garage in Illinois but there
was a problem Curtis had nowhere to sell
the product dippin dots need to be
stored at such a cold temperature that
it made it impossible for grocery stores
to house the tasty treat so he got
creative and marketed his product to
alternate locations now they're sold at
amusement parks festivals zoos and other
summertime destinations but whether or
not they really are the ice cream of the
future it will just have to wait and see
[Music]